the efficacy in the real world  is in part waning because the virus  variant that is dominant now is not the  one that the vaccine was developed  against  this is different then vaccine efficacy  goes down against the live variant the  original variant against which the  vaccines were designed it may or it may  not but we don't yet have reason to  believe that and so this may well become  like a flu shot type situation  where i'm scheduled to get my flu shot  in a few days myself the flu shot i will  get in a few days  is based on what was believed to be the  dominant strain at the time that this  year's flu shot started to be developed  i don't know if it's six or eight months  ago  and depending on how well that matches  what's actually out there in this  upcoming flu season i will have a lower  or higher degree of protection